anyway
[Music]
sure
good afternoon so today the european
commission has dispersed 14 billion euro
in loans to nine eu
countries under the shore instrument
which is as you know the instrument the
eu instrument that protects
jobs and workers in the pandemic croatia
has received
510 million euro cyprus 250
million euro greece 2 billion
italy an additional 6.5 billion
latvia 120 million
lithuania 300 million malta 120 million
slovenia 200 million and spain an
additional
4 billion euro now this support in the
form of loans granted
on favorable terms will help these
member states in addressing increases in
public expenditure to preserve
employment
commission has so far proposed to make
90.3
billion euro in financial support
available to 18 member states
thank you very much balash now i passed
the floor to tim
for an announcement on our energy
efficiency policy
thanks eric um good morning everybody
the commission has today launched two
further public consultations
as part of its work to deliver on our
ambitious new emissions reduction
targets for 2030 which were proposed in
september
these consultations on the review of the
renewable energy directive and the
energy efficiency directive
will ensure that eu policies in these
areas can contribute to reducing
greenhouse gas emissions by at least 55
percent by 2030 compared to 1990 levels
the path to climate neutrality requires
us to scale up the production
of renewable energy and reinforce our
action on energy efficiency
in the next decade this consultation
will help to shape the legislative
proposals which the commission is due to
make in the summer of next year
the commission is looking forward to
receiving feedback from all stakeholders
all interested parties on these two
consultations in addition to the four
climate related consultations which we
announced yesterday
thank you tim
video conference
and i pass the floor to lotte
yes hello can you hear me yes go ahead
yeah um i have a two questions regarding
the mink situation still in in denmark
uh just uh you to know if you can give
us a little more information about the
conversation yesterday between us
underline and our prime minister um
what they talked about and also
sort of for the willingness in general
from the commission's side to look
at the danish wish to compensate
the mink farmers that now have really to
close
for the rest of the year and also for
the whole next year and maybe they will
never
be back in in in business again
what's in general your your view on on
the danish wish to compensate as much as
possible
and how do you see the the red lines
uh regarding stay date thank you
thank you very much latte indeed there
was
yesterday early afternoon a phone call
between
the danish prime minister mrs
frederickson and the president of the
commission
and um as the very short readout which
we gave
by a tweet said the
conversation focused on the issue
of coronavirus in denmark and in
particular
the situation which you are referring to
with regards um
to uh minx and the policy vis-a-vis the
calling
uh of minx um as we said um
clearly this is an ongoing issue and
there's not much that i can add on the
content
of the of the conversation except to say
indeed
that the issue of the compensation was
uh
was raised now i passed the floor
to ariana on your more specific
questions related to that
good morning lot and what i can add to
what eric has already said
is that indeed the commission is in
close and constructive contact with the
danish authorities on
on this matter to explore all possible
solutions
in line with danish and european union
laws
thank you are there other questions
for us latte you have a follow-up but
i'm afraid really that we're not going
to be able to go further than what we
have already said
but go ahead okay i'll just give it a
try
can you just put some maybe a little
more words on the red lines
what is that is it that the danish
government has to look for
when they are putting together a package
for compensation
thanks lot but as eric says has said at
this stage
there's not much more we can add it
would be really premature to say
anything else
other than that we are in very close and
constructive contact with the danish
authorities
thank you are there other issues on
minx in denmark and state aid please
only keep your hand raised
if this is the case
[Music]
stefan
[Music]
[Music]
um
a
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
um i have a question on vaccines as well
and on the contract signed by the
commission
with some producer producer
what happens if one of those vaccines
does not succeed or does not
get the authorization for emma
i mean would you pay
anyway the the the money
um that is objective of the
of the deal or a share of it
uh how could you could you tell us how
will it work in this case thank you
i passed the floor to stefan again
thank you very much marco thank you for
this very good question indeed
um you know that we want to develop as
i've said already a few times a
diversified and broad portfolio of
different vaccine candidates
we do not know at this stage which
vaccine candidate will be successful or
not
which one will be effective and safe of
course there's already quite some
positive reporting on some vaccines
which we welcome
very much but in in order to
broaden this uh portfolio we felt it
necessary
um to conclude vex these advanced
purchase agreements with different
vaccine developers we expect from these
vaccine developers
that they are ready to make available
very big numbers of vaccines quickly as
soon as
the vaccine turns out to be successful
safe and
sure but to help companies to to have
this capacity we of course as a
commission
are ready to invest in the development
of this
in production capacity again companies
have to be able to immediately proceed
with the production of hundreds of
millions of vaccines when
the vaccine turns out to be successful
so we know and we knew that from the
beginning that there is always a risk
that investments that are made may not
lead to indeed successful vaccines again
we try to reduce this risk by having
investments in several companies but we
are aware that
yes there is a risk that some of the
investment
will not come to successful vaccines
this being said i would like to stress
however that these investments
in production capacity are always
important
also in the context of building protect
production capacity
strengthening production capacities in
the european union
when it comes to development of
medicines and vaccines thank you
thank you very much catherine you have
a health related question please go
ahead
whoops yes uh eric i hope
my question had to run down and answer
the door because the postman
didn't know the midday was on but
anyways um
uh i hope this question hasn't been
asked but yesterday when
the president did her presentation about
her statement on vaccines she mentioned
that there had been
tangible progress with curvac i'm just
wondering if you could say a little bit
more about what
tangible progress means does it you know
which phase of uh
trials is it in and
she also said that there would be up to
405 million doses
ordered and you know given that
um moderna which seems very promising
uh given that the exploratory talks
only led to an order of well a potential
order of 160 million
does that show your
confidence in this particular vaccine or
is it linked to the fact
that the eu was an early investor in
this company
via the european investment bike
thank you again question for stefan
thank you there's lots of questions in
in this uh question
um um as far as qrak is concerned yes we
have
um uh the president has announced that
we are that the college will give you
the green light to the signature of a
contract for
405 million doses which is
225 doses plus an
option of 180 million as far as moderna
is concerned
during the in the context of the
finalization of the exploratory talks we
agreed
on 160 million doses 80 million plus 80
million
as far as modernity is concerned of
course we continue to
have the negotiations and we will see um
uh
in how any which type of how this will
be translated into an
actual uh um contract
we cannot however comment on the actual
specific state of
uh where we are with the clinical trials
we take note obviously of of the
statements that have been done
by the different companies what is
important is that
the actual evaluation as to the
efficiency
and the safety of these vaccines will be
done by the european medicines agency as
you know they have an extremely
important role to play and it's up to
them
to assess uh to what extent the vaccines
that have been developed
respect these fundamental criteria of
safety and effectiveness
thank you thank you stefan
thank you follow up catherine
uh can i just ask the the 405 million
versus
uh 160 overall you know immediate and
you know in the pipeline
orders of doses does that reflect your
confidence
in that vaccine
stefan yes hello we
conclude contracts with vaccine
developers
whenever we have confidence indeed that
there is
a good chance of having an effective and
safe vaccine otherwise we would not
conclude the contracts
the numbers of course of the doses these
are things that depend on many factors
factors and criteria which have been
laid down in our vaccine strategy
which has to do with the production
capacity which have to do with them
delivery times which have to do with
costs which has to do with technology
and so on
but the fact that we sign an advanced
purchase agreement with a company
means that we of course hope that this
vaccine that the vaccine developer is
working on will turn out to be
successful and safe
thank you thanks
thanks catherine one last follow-up but
then i will move on to your
many colleagues who are waiting yeah
sorry about that uh eric uh sorry about
that
but uh one aspect that stefan didn't
address
is the fact that the eu has funded this
company curve via the european
investment bank and does that have any
bearing on
your decision and do we get mates rates
for doses
uh if we are an investor in that company
stefan mate rate
rates i'm sorry i'm not sure i
understood the question about rates
yeah the the friendly rate but catherine
perhaps
i can answer that question yeah
the fact is that the commission
is stefan
the commission is uh negotiating with
companies
which since the beginning it believes
have the potential to deliver
a a vaccine that that works
that is effective okay but however
because when we started this we need to
remember that we started this
quite some months ago before the before
the summer
um we could not be sure of which
technology
which uh company would uh would come up
with uh the quickest best um
effective vaccine so that's why we went
for what we call a portfolio
approach um so clearly we did our
homework we
we analyzed what we thought were
promising uh possibilities and then we
started these negotiation
on advanced purchasing agreements one
company
has indeed or some companies have
received um
funding of some sort our loans in
particular for the ib curve
is one but it's not the only one if i
remember well um
as well obviously what we are doing is
negotiating
bulk contracts um
using the fact that we are 450 million
europeans
in order to get good rates that's the
whole objective now what you need to
remember
is that it's not the commission that is
buying
the vaccines it will be the member
states what we are doing is indeed as
you quite rightly say
negotiating the best possible conditions
for delivery of those vaccines to member
states
should decide to buy them okay
and as stefan has said we what we are
doing is we are investing
in those companies research development
and production capacities in europe
in order to ensure that they can develop
this vaccine
and if approved by the european
medicines agency
that these vaccines can then be
distributed
to europeans as quickly as possible
but ultimately it is the member states
who buy
the vaccines
okay let's continue on this theme um
[Music]
um
[Music]
[Music]
me
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
angela you have a question on vaccines
yes hello sorry my camera doesn't work i
sorry for this yeah i have a question on
the deals on vaccines i read
quite a lot of criticism on the fact
that the commission is signing deals
on the basis of the press releases or
the announcements
by the companies pfizer
or moderna if this is gonna be the case
uh i was wondering is this um
is is this true that the the deals are
being signed only on the basis of press
releases without
any scientific publication on the
vaccines which
have been announced and how do you reply
to this criticism
and one another quick question on the
deals as well
uh how do you reply to the
associations ngos or
who the people who are asking that the
contracts
deals should be public in order to
be able to control prices and the
distribution
of the vaccines thanks so much bye
thank you yes
thank you very much um on your first
question are we simply
concluding contracts because all of a
sudden there are some nice press reports
about the state of play of this vaccine
i think eric has already replied to this
a few days ago saying that is
clearly not the case we are taking these
negotiations extremely seriously it goes
through
two phases a first negotiation which
leads to the conclusion of exploratory
talks
where we agree have kind of a
pre-agreement on the number of doses
and then we have the second part where
we try to
translate this into an advanced purchase
agreement this is
complex negotiations we're talking about
very important topics
it's very technical so this takes time
and we take this
very seriously with the help of
a negotiation team the negotiation is
being done by negotiation team support
by
uh scientific evidence so this is done
extremely seriously
any um statement uh which would say that
we're just following the waves
of of media on this are not correct
second what do we say about the request
to
publish these contracts well i think
this is also something that has been
raised already a few times in this
press room it is extremely important to
know that we are having negotiations in
a very
sensitive environment there's quite some
information which is
sensitive business information which
cannot be
shared i'm talking for instance about
the price or
development processes or production
processes which are part
of the confidential business information
and therefore covered
by confidentiality clauses and we have
to respect
these clauses i would like to stress
immediately that this is not only in the
interest of these companies but it's
also in
our interest we want to preserve
the integrity of the negotiations that
are still ongoing with other companies
if we were to publish this very
sensitive
information whilst negotiations are
still ongoing with other companies you
make these negotiations extremely
difficult
and i would doubt that it would be in
the interest of the
european citizens for which we try to
reach correct
agreements as far as transparency is
concerned finally
i believe that several measures are
taken to
be as transparent as possible on any
topic which has to do with the
development of these contracts
our chief negotiator has gone to the
european parliament we are organizing
webinars so
there's a lot is being done to show
where we are and to keep
everybody informed on the state of play
of things thank you
thank you the fact is um angela that we
started
discussions with the vaccine developers
extremely early right
way before the summer if you if you
remember well
um and therefore um there is uh
a parallelism uh between the work that
they have been on doing in terms
that they have been doing sorry in terms
of developing the vaccine
and the discussions that uh that we have
had with them
all over the all over the summer but we
are not linking
the signature uh or approval of any
contract with any specific
um with any specific announcement the
fact is that in many of the cases the
uh preliminary discussions were
concluded some time ago already
so well before the the announcements but
then uh
signing up drawing up the contracts and
getting them approved by
uh by the college um take some take some
time as i had the opportunity of saying
already
last week i believe lorenzo
on this issue
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
the
[Music]
um
[Music]
the risk of
is
european aviation safety agency and the
ecdc european disease
disease prevention and control agencies
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
um
you have the floor
thanks eric uh if i could just follow up
with uh stefan
on the issue of transparency and the
handling here i wonder
if the commission at any point consulted
any experts on procurement given the
complete unique nature of these
purchases
there's just never been a situation like
this that we can think of where the
demand would be so
universal and um across the entire world
and so perhaps has there been any
consideration to the to the fact that
perhaps the
the usual practices followed in
procurement some of these
confidentiality mechanisms
do not in fact serve european taxpayers
in this circumstance because that
perhaps the only way
to keep prices down uh for the public
would be complete and full transparency
about the investments that are being
made by the public
and the cost of development of the
vaccines and some
transparent understanding uh discussion
even debate
about how much profit might be
reasonable
in that setting was there any expert
consultation to consider whether in fact
the old rules
should not apply in this circumstance
thanks thank you stefan thank you steve
um this is a very important procurement
process you're right
now we have the advantage of being held
by
a lot of specialists in the area of
procurement
we have very strict rules in the area of
procurement
and it's for us absolutely fundamental
and crucial that we make sure
that these rules are respected we are
aware
that at any time what we do can be
audited because we are
accountable towards the european
citizens and towards um
the the budgetary authority so at any
time we can be ordered so
we have made sure that with the help of
all the specialists that we have in the
house
the rules that we follow are the rules
that should be fought and are correct
and that we are uh in line with them as
far as
publicity is concerned i reiterate the
fact
that there are confidentiality clauses
that
have to be respected with regard to
information that comes from companies
but also and again it is in our interest
that we can follow a procedure the
tendering rules the contracting rules
making use of these confidentiality
clauses um
otherwise it would become it risks
making the negotiations
harder than they already are thank you
so david this is not opposing old rules
and
new rules first of all the commission is
not a body that can simply
simply decide not to respect uh
regulatory frameworks uh in place we
have to follow
uh the the rules as uh as they are and
let me remind you that it takes two to
tango when you are negotiating uh
with a partner um it's not as you can
simply
impose on the partner your conditions
for the for the negotiation
right uh or else there is no negotiation
that is uh that is possible
remember these are of course uh
companies
that all are developing products on the
market we are negotiating with
quite a few companies at the at the same
time
um and therefore you have to
you have to ensure that you can carry
out the negotiations
with the individual companies
in in such a way as to get to a to a
result and therefore we followed
the process that you know well and on
which we have also organized here
a technical briefing um in the firm
belief that it is
the best and quickest way of delivering
a result
i see one more hand raised on the issue
of
health um i pass the floor to louise
yes hello eric and stefan just a quick
question on any future contracts
as far as i know apart from moderna and
kurovac there have also been
preliminary talks with novobacks and
could there be
any other deals with any other companies
in the pipeline
thanks thank you again a question for
stefan
yes uh thank you um we want to develop a
as i said before a diversified portfolio
using different
technologies different approaches so
that we increase the chances of ending
up with the effective and safe
virus so we will do that we will we are
negotiating
with companies as far as names are
concerned
who we are having still negotiations
with
this information that we do not share as
soon as we have reached a situation
where we have
concluded successfully exploratory talks
we will obviously
share this but for the time being i
cannot say more on this matter
thank you thank you stefan
okay i think this closes the health
chapter
so i now open the floor to other
um questions um we
have a question from nuremberg
what could be the european union
reaction if trump administration
or israel launched strikes against the
nuclear sites in iran
more precisely mr ludlion and haikumas
wrote a paper or opinion today in the
moment
calling the next the new administration
or
elect vader when he will be in office to
have a
common approach with the european union
to deal with the problem related to the
nuclear deal
in iran but also to have a common
european-american
approach towards the crisis in the east
mediterranean
can peter tell us what could be the
contribution of both sides to solve
the problems posed in with the nuclear
related to the
nuclear deal with iran and
also to the problem in post today
in east mediterranean thank you thank
you nadine i'm going to give peter the
floor but you know
very well that we do not answer
hypothetical questions like the one you
have asked the beginning
of your intervention on what would be
your reaction if there was
a strike against any any country so uh
peter will definitely not answer that
question but i give him the floor on the
second one
good afternoon thank you and indeed of
course we we never speculate on
what if scenarios but on other aspects
of your question
indeed and it was very obvious from the
first
messages and reactions from the european
countries after the
u.s presidential elections that europe
is expecting and europe is prepared to
work more closely with the united states
new presidential administration based on
more cooperation
more dialogue and if we want to build a
stronger
friendship and better partnership then
of course the europe is prepared for it
there are many areas where we can
work together and where we have actually
interest to work together
in the foreign policy issue you
mentioned some of them that's iran but
it's also russia that's uh the eastern
neighborhood so libya
the middle east balkans as well and of
course turkey and the eastern
mediterranean
so in the past since eu and u.s
are based on shared values and we have
so many historical links and practical
links among
ourselves and we have the same political
systems in the past
always when we worked together on some
issue we were always more effective and
more successful
and this is something the eu is
expecting also now from the
new administration incoming
administration in two days time the
ministers of foreign affairs of the eu
member states will meet for the video
conference so
informal uh foreign first council
because it's not possible to meet in
person
and they this will be the first
opportunity for them to discuss among
themselves uh how they see
uh europe's contribution to develop this
stronger partnership and better
friendship with the
united states under the new
administration so this is work in
progress
but the eu was very clear already in
signaling that we are interested in more
cooperation in more dialogue because we
are
we are facing many challenges in the
current world
and we will be more successful when we
tackle them together and iran is one of
them so
there is uh even cautious optimism when
it comes to the
indications from uh mr biden that he
um intends to approach the iran issue
completely different to what
mr trump chose in terms of um
handling iran so we will be waiting once
the new administration is in place
unveils its policies but as i said there
is cautious optimism that
when it comes to iran they will change
the overall dynamic
and we will not have to speculate about
um
hypothetical scenarios thank you peter
so let us stay no ready in follow-up but
quick please because we are running out
of time we have a technical briefing
coming up
what could the united states and
european union do together to solve the
crisis in the region
i think this is abroad because i'm not
really sure what you think uh what you
have in mind regarding the crisis in the
region unless i miss uh missed start of
the
of your question but i will just
reiterate we are now discussing
what will or what should be the use
contribution
in order to reach out to the new
administration the discussions are
ongoing they started only only a few
weeks ago after in the aftermath of the
elections
and uh what is bottom line and the main
objective
of the eu is to build a stronger
partnership to renew the close
cooperation and the dialogue with the
united states
and to deal with all the challenges of
the world nowadays together when we join
forces we are always more successful and
this is in our shared interest
thank you peter so we remain on foreign
affairs please only keep your hand
raised if your question concerns foreign
affairs
and i pass the floor to alexandra
can you hear me yes okay thank you
thank you for taking my question so a
question on g20
as you know last month's european
lawmakers urged uh commissioned
president fonder line european council
president michelle not to attend the g20
summit
uh virtual summit in saudi arabia to
downgrade
eu's presence there due to human rights
violations
they also wrote a letter didn't get a
response yet
apparently so my question is am i right
assuming that
uh president fonder lion is attending
this summit we'll attend this summit
nonetheless
and what message do you want to send to
all those
people who have been victims of human
rights violations in saudi arabia in
particular to women's rights activists
who are currently in jail
thank you thank you very much alexandria
for your
question yes i can confirm that
president van der line
will be taking part in what is a
multilateral
event called the g20 which
is hosted by the current rotating
chair which is saudi arabia
this g20 will be attended by
all the leaders of the of the g20 and i
think it is extremely important
to distinguish between a multilateral
form of discussion that will be
discussing um some of the key challenges
that the planet as a whole faces and in
particular
obviously the current uh the current
health crisis that we face but also
uh climate change etc from
our bilateral um concerns vis-a-vis
human rights uh and our bilateral
relation uh
with uh with saudi arabia i will call
nadila
um to to the podium to tell you a bit
more
about what we do on these serious
serious concerns that you have that you
have raised
sorry it's peter not nabila yes
apologies peter andy thank you and
exactly i mean it's very important to
delink the multilateral and bilateral
aspect and on the bilateral track
the eu is uh constantly following very
closely
what is going on in saudi arabia when it
comes to the situation
uh of uh respect of human rights and
situation of people who are
defending the human rights uh including
individual cases
and we are vocal both in the public
statements when it's necessary but also
in the diplomatic outreach which
we are doing towards our saudi partners
so this is
quite high on our agenda because human
rights are one of the principles on
which the eu is based and
we are not uh deviating from this in the
contact with the partners even though
they don't like it
and our contacts with saudi arabia have
intensified anyway over the last few
months
and we've been raising our concerns and
we discussed further
how to improve the human rights
situation the protection of human rights
in the kingdom
and we will continue to pay utmost
attention to this question in in the
run-up to the g20 summit
and afterwards because as i as eric has
explained this is a multilateral fora to
deal with completely different issues
under the presidency which is rotating
but
our dialogue with saudi arabia continues
beyond this summit and we will continue
to engage
to raise the issues um regarding human
rights with the saudi partners
and also in coordination with the eu
special representative for human rights
and all the other relevant stakeholders
so for us this is like ongoing
discussion
and it's in a discussion where we pay a
lot of attention
to to engage with the partners
thank you you have a follow-up alexander
thank you just a quick follow-up world
human rights
violation be raised at the g20 summit
from the eu's perspective
alexandra we do not fix the agenda of
the g20
these are events which follow a very
very strict
agenda and uh and protocol order when it
comes to
to speaking and of course these are the
conditions under which the commission
will be
participating in the g20 i think that
peter has very
clearly explained that there are many
channels of communication
to raise our concerns related to human
rights
in our dialogue our bilateral dialogue
with saudi arabia
i passed the floor to james now on a
different subject james
on belarus not on brexit not on brexit
not no not on not on brexit uh eric
um yeah belarus those reports from
belarus
uh saying that the government has
suspended dialogue on human rights with
the eu
reduced participation in the eastern
partnership and has proposed the
suspension
of the belarus eu coordination group i'm
wondering
uh if you guys have any reaction uh to
that
and if you could give us a rundown on
basically what the state of play is
and where we stand on everything with
the sanctions and
eu belarus relations thank you
thank you again a question for peter
thank you and i'll be very brief because
the belarus will be also one of the
topics discussed in today's time on
thursday during the informal
foreign first council or the video
conference of the foreign ministers of
the eu
so i would uh not preempt those
discussions but the position of the eu
is very clear
we don't uh recognize the legitimacy of
lukashenka
as as a head of state and the dialogue
between the eu and belarus at the
official level was
already suspended a long time ago in
response to the unacceptable shameful
events
from the side of the state authority so
we reduce reduced everything
in our engagement with official
belarusian authorities to expert level
anyway
and the overall review is ongoing how to
shape further our relations
so so belarusian authorities instead of
trying to to make news of their
suspension in
eastern partnership or in the format
they are engaging with the eu
should really address the big issues
they have at home and that's the
repression of their own population
and trying to see how to launch the
inclusive national dialogue about the
solution and how to meet the legitimate
expectations and demands of their people
the dialogue between the eu and belarus
uh was was already
it was already changed and downgraded to
a very bare
expert level so this is this is the
state of play now we are
reviewing all the programs we want to
support below russian people civil
society citizens
and as i said the discussions will be
taken further in today's time
by the foreign ministers including the
discussions about possible
extension of the restrictive measures
meaning sanctions
thank you let's stay on issues related
to
foreign affairs marcus you have a
question
on foreign affairs
marcus becker
oops do you hear me yes we do go ahead
marcus yeah good
thanks uh well my question would be
about poland hungary in the budget i
don't know if that qualifies as
foreign affairs actually i believe
that it doesn't so we will come back to
you afterwards
[Music]
christian questions exterior
[Music]
[Music]
okay um a related question
not related but also foreign affairs if
we if we can
consider it like that a question on
brexit from verena
on eu uk relations i would say
very now you still with us
you do not seem to be with us anymore or
oh you're there okay go ahead your
your mic source apparently is
problematic
yes
there are reports as we speak that
negotiators are aiming for a deal
early next week and i was wondering if
you could comment on that thank you
we do not comment on reports on
on on any subject as you know so what is
clear is that we continue to negotiate
intensively with our uk partners and we
aim
obviously to find to find a deal when
the conditions
will be there but we're not going to
comment and
give a blow or by blow account of um of
what negotiators
are working towards i'm very sorry
okay i see one hand
uh raised for the moment on another
issue i suspect
atanasius marcus i have not forgotten
you we'll come back to you
thanks very much thanks very much it's
another issue of course it's an
administrative
issue last week i've asked you about the
allegations on lack of fairness and
equal practice in the ongoing
episode competition but i didn't get an
answer
so let me repeat there is a secretary's
competition here in brussels that's
ongoing
but it has been simultaneously cancelled
in many other countries giving a clear
advantage
of more time to study for many of those
candidates
so my question is how is this compatible
to equity
in equal practice that has to be
embedded in the practices
of absorb thank you
good afternoon so um it's a pretty
specific question but um in general of
course
just like the eu institutions follow the
rules of the hosting states
episode has to do the same as you know
epso has testing centers around the
world in a very
large number of countries and the rules
that have been introduced in the context
of the current virus
crisis also applied to to epsilon
so what does this mean in practice in
practice of course the rules differ in
the different countries where um
epso has testing centers um which is why
in some countries it's possible to to
keep centers open whereas in other
countries it is not possible
now the the principle of of uh equality
of course uh
applies and episode does everything it
can to ensure that candidates can
uh take um their uh test in the
center of their preference and when
this is not possible individual
solutions will be
will be sought but the utmost priority
remains
that we would like to make sure that
every single candidate gets to take
his or her test at the center of his or
her
preference attendance
you have a follow-up
yes i have a follow-up because i'm
asking the exact
opposite of that the point is not having
some
taking the exam now and some others
later the point is having everybody
taking the exam at the same time
so everybody has the same study time
that's what they are telling you
anyway the other thing the other aspect
of the situation is the
profit crisis you rightfully mention it
but since the european commission itself
has turned back to phase zero where only
critical stuff is allowed in the office
don't you think that there is some kind
of loss of credibility when one of your
dgs namely ebso is still continuing the
exams
which to an external observer is nothing
more than meetings of many people
in small rooms for three hours how you
can do that thanks
well i think the key point to make here
is that um
when we make decisions in terms of our
approach to
our administration during copy times we
are looking at the measures
of the countries where our offices are
located most of which can be found of
course
in uh belgium but we have also a
significant presence in luxembourg
and and italy so when we take decisions
on um
on our return to office strategy we look
at the measures that are in place in
these countries
now as i said epso has a much broader
presence around the world not only
um in eu member states but also beyond
um and in fact they are present in every
single
member states so when they decide on
whether to
keep an office open or not they look at
the applicable measures
in the countries in question
thank you banash i now go back to
marcus becker and your question on the
mff and the
rule of law
yes hi thank you
so i would have a couple of technical
questions about this
so um well as you know there was the
video against the uh
the mff regulation and the resource
decision by hungary poland so what i
would like to know is
uh what is the last deadline for the
commission to have an agreement there to
be able to
set up the budget for 2021
and what do the the treaties or the
regulations the respective ones
say about if a budget would not be in
place
in time which uh which kind of money
would flow uh would keep on flowing at
which post would would not
from 2021 thank you
yes so when you say budget then i take
it to i take it that you refer to the
mff
and the mff regulation namely so you
know the process for the mff regulation
is basically the special legislative
procedure
this means that we need a agreement in
the council and then
the consent of the parliament is also
needed
so this process is ongoing and we are we
are focusing on the commission side
on making sure that this process can go
forward um
as as planned therefore i'm not able to
give you any
particular deadline at this point in
time we are working on it and we would
like to make sure that the decisions
that need to be taken are taken and the
mff regulation is adopted by the 1st
of january
thank you other question on
this on this issue
tommaso a question on the budget
hi good afternoon yes it's on the budget
so uh
following the veto of yesterday uh to
the on resources decision
does the commission acknowledge uh that
there will be
delays in the disbursement of the
recovery and resilient facility
or are you still confident that the
funds will be available to the member
states
by the end of the spring thank you
look i think the question is uh to
ensure that
um that we can come to a resolution
of this issue and the conclusion of all
the steps uh
that are necessary um as quickly as
possible
we had a long discussion on this
yesterday
and we said at the time that our
focus is not on trying to calculate
at this point in time any new uh
schedule for disbursements
it is to make sure that we find um that
we find
um an agreement and as you know in july
the member states
agreed on on three things on
on the on the budget on the multi
financial framework on next generation
eu and on rule of law
uh conditionality so what we are
focusing on
at the moment um is making sure
uh with the rotating presidency and with
the president of the european council
that we can find a solution um to
uh to this and 25 member states
basically have uh are not contesting
the implementation of the agreement of
last july as you said yourself
we have two member states which uh for
the moment
have taken a position on this and so
what
the objective is is to try to make sure
that we can find
an agreement on the basis of what was
agreed in july
in order to move in order to move
forward as quickly as possible
david
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
function
you
um
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
who